[Música]
[Aplausos]
en la universidad
trabajé cinco años en empresas
internacionales
un buen día
decidí irme para australia quería
ahorrar y conocer el sudeste asiático
era un sueño
así lo hice viaje para para tailandia
hice un curso de kung fu
y seguí viaje a laos
en el año 2014 en junio del año 2014
este viaje de turismo se convirtió
en una odisea por salvar la vida de un
niño
que no conocía
ahí estaba aún
al costado de una canchita de fútbol
con su panza a punto de reventar
me sonrío
le sonreí
y en ese instante
me di cuenta que tenía que hacer algo
en ese instante empecé a ver a todos los
costados rodeado de jungla
casitas hechas de caña
no había recursos en ese instante fue
que me dije cueste lo que me cueste le
voy a salvar la vida a este chico
así fue como corriendo a visitar a la
familia de él me encontré con un su mamá
y le dije sin conocer el idioma de ellos
porque ellos hablan en la océano
y le digo tomorrow hospital pipe al
hospital con una euforia que creo que se
dio cuenta lo que le estaba diciendo y
al día siguiente nos estaban oyendo los
al primer hospital de laos en la capital
de laos en vientián
estuve con él un total de 10 días ahí
hasta que al décimo día
el doctor
se acerca y me dice no sé qué tienes aún
no sé qué hacer no sé qué enfermedad
tiene me quedé helado no podía creer lo
que me estaba diciendo
qué agua ahora decía yo lo dejo ahí ya
está
ni loco decía yo hay un fuego dentro mío
no sé de dónde venía ya me lo dio los
ángeles lo que sea que me decía si me
fui para tailandia solo en busca de un
doctor que lo salve
estuve 5 días en tailandés tocando la
puerta del cual hospital se me cruzaba
hay quien todavía encuentro a este
doctor que me dice trae lo que vamos a
ver qué podemos hacer en un cuadro
durísimo
vuelvo para klaus feliz y contento
la buena noticia nos vamos
no tenían pasaportes y dni nada
siguiente obstáculo
qué hago
corriendo al ministerio de relaciones
exteriores los tres con sauna a cuestas
entramos al ministerio y por arte de
magia siempre digo que es por arte de
magia en 24 horas teníamos los
pasaportes hechos
el antes y el después de la historia
no podía creer lo que estaba pasando
la historia en la que estaba el fuego
dentro mío que me decía
sí sí sí sí
los pasaportes genial
al día siguiente en avión
nos fuimos a tailandia
acá pongan un segundito en los zapatos
enfermo sufre
y si estaba subiendo a un avión
nunca he salido de su aldea con una
persona que a gatas conocía
este es un trayecto
increíble
llorando a lágrima tendida pensando en
lo que me había pasado en todas las
cosas
se me pasaban por la cabeza me pueden
acusar de trata de gente qué sé yo
pero también llorando por la expectativa
y la incertidumbre de lo que se me venía
me podía morir hoy
tremendo esto
estuvimos con él
un total de 60 días en bangkok la
capital de tailandia
son días increíbles
hasta una lección dos y dos cirugías
tratamiento
dolorosísimo gritaba lloraba
nunca me despegué tuve poner los 60 días
dos veces al día con él enseñó de todo
inglés
pero sobre todo la diseñada decir centro
agradezca a todo aquel que los que lo
había ayudado
aún hoy es un niño que corre
que ríe
es un niño feliz
le dice genio a todo el mundo
hasta el mundo que se le cruza procesos
tienen contacto con él
es impresionante se reconstruyó una casa
tiene un futuro me empecé a dar cuenta
que podía cambiar la vida de la gente
esto fue también a muchísima gente a mi
costado
yo me di cuenta que le quería dar un
sentido a este viaje en el sudeste
quería seguir ir a conocer más
así fue como llegué a filipinas a una
fundación
que rescata chicos de la trata de gente
200 chicos habían esas fundas en esa
fundación pero hubo una que el primer
día que llegue la funda a la fundación
viene corriendo el vídeo más
con sus ojos a punto de salirse de su
cara porque su cráneo crecía en punta el
cerebro presionaba
y me contaron ese día que ya vino y que
me abrazo
y yo ay me di cuenta la razón por la que
estaba ahí también
que sufría mucho
bien la directora de la fundación y me
dice no sé qué hacer con esta chica
duerme dos horas al día
pues porque todo el sufrimiento que
tiene hice lo mismo que con sound
buscando los doctores adonde no existían
y lo dimos todo absolutamente todo fue
una odisea también
anabel hoy corre ríe llora protesta
pero feliz
y una segunda chance
me di cuenta que este a donde esté
vos tomando acciones te puedes salvar la
vida área
pero no todo fue en el sudeste
o argentina de un poquito de hombres y
argentina bueno vamos
en córdoba cuyo del 2017 salina castro
me llama y me dice mi hijo nació con
microcefalia
y los doctores no quiere hacer más nada
con él porque no hay solución
me fui para córdoba al día siguiente
me junte con ella armamos toda una
estrategia para que su hijo tenga una
segunda chance
no a hoy vive en una casa acorde a su
condición está siendo rehabilitado
gracias a muchísima gente viajó a
ecuador 5 en cinco ocasiones
es un chiquito
que acciona los estímulos
que te mira que se ríe nuestros sueños
que camine investiguen lo que es
microcefalia imposible todo el mundo
dice imposible imposible no es nada
pues sí que está acá realmente realmente
entonces empecé a pensar en todo esto
está pasando todo esto todas estas
historias tienen una conclusión
me di cuenta que todo esto sucedía
gracias a cinco cosas
cinco cosas hacían que yo pueda ayudar a
otros les cuento cuáles son
contacto con doctores especialistas
asistentes sociales comunidades gente
que me ayudaba en las tareas diarias
díaz mentores que me decían cómo hacer
las cosas
acceso a la reclamación de fondos en
cada caso y el acceso a los medios de
comunicación importantísimo había que
comunicar todo
todas estas cinco cosas hicieron que yo
pueda ayudar a otros
sino como la super idea de que si todos
contamos con estas cinco cosas le
podemos cambiar la vida quien querramos
ustedes acá cuantos son 100
todos ustedes cien con estas cosas le
pueden cambiar la vida que ustedes
quieran en situación de vulnerabilidad
entonces junto a
tomen y se va empezamos a diseñar esta
idea sound
un ecosistema que acompañe a todo aquel
que le quiera cambiar la vida a otro en
situación de vulnerabilidad pero a uno
solo
el único condicionamiento es que tienes
que elegir a uno
en contraturno empezamos a decir según
te acompaña a que vos le cambie la vida
a quien vos quieras en situación de
vulnerabilidad cómo funciona este existe
este ecosistema
ustedes pueden decidir dos cosas o tomar
la iniciativa de cambiar la vida es uno
y se convierten en lo que llamamos sobre
el sound líder o están tomando un rol
dentro de todo el soporte para la acción
para empoderar a ese sound líder ustedes
ayudan la forma que ustedes quieran
esto está para que ayuden a gente que
quiere cambiar la vida de otros
y en donde estén no importa
como hizo alejandro un abogado de
capital se contactó con sal con un con
la iniciativa de querer cambiar la vida
de una familia que estaba viviendo en la
calle
parecía para muchos tiempos imposible
esto una familia entera
obtuvo en el ecosistema todo lo
necesario equipo recaudó fondos
especialistas con esta comunidad
comunicación salió las tasas en los
diarios
hoy es una familia que vive en un hogar
chicos escolar escolarizados y como
siempre decimos hay que agradecer
agradecen a todo el mundo
entonces
qué conclusión sacamos de todo esto mi
conclusión es
según somos todos todos tenemos la
intención de ayudar a alguien todos
conocemos a alguien a quien la está
pasando
realmente mal que está en vulnerabilidad
y queremos hacer algo pero no sabemos
cómo tenemos incertidumbre y queremos
dar ese primer paso y de la intención a
la acción se puede obvio que se puede y
como decían recién no busquemos una
solución a todo porque es imposible eso
es real
pero podemos encontrar a uno
cambiar de la vida
y le estaremos cambiando también a
nosotros nos convertiremos en personas
mejores
todo lo que pase acá va a estar bien
para estar mejor
entonces les digo
desde ese paso si conocen a ese quien
hace al 15
estamos también para sacar todas esas
dudas que ustedes pueden ustedes son los
actores de que su historia no le den la
problemática a otro háganlo ustedes que
ustedes pueden ser ese protagonista que
otro está necesitando
encuentren su no empoderen ser por el
ecosistema y cambien de la vida muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]